whenever the bank of England prints a
ton of money especially when it's a lot
of money and whenever the government
gives out a lot of money you need to be
asking where that money is going to end
up so essentially what we have here is a
situation where the government has
slashed taxes on rich people this is
after the three years which have seen
the biggest and fastest ever increase in
millionaire and billionaire wealth in
the country okay
the government has now slashed taxes on
them the market has said well we think
that's that makes you financially
unsustainable so we're basically going
to pull a plug on you and the bank of
England is basically coming in and
funding it so now you have a situation
where the bank of England is essentially
funding a massive cash transfer from the
government to the rich on the back of
the biggest ever cash transfer we've
ever seen from the government to the
rich and I want to put some numbers on
this you know because I think it's
amazing I don't think people realize you
know if you were to tax the wealthy
enough now to make them as rich as they
were before covert started you could
give every single adult in the country
twelve thousand pounds